thank you
oh yeah I got some sound now one two
Bruce Springsteen is a few inches away
from me and I am I'm Starstruck
I have so many questions so let me just
dive in sounds great I love what you say
about your dad boy do I relate to that
it was tough my role model my father was
not giving I was born in blue and
weather all I know I am his agent in the
world and I'm going to make something
out of your story
[Music]
a lot of my work if not most of it
that's the root of it
[Music]
so you're sitting there with Clarence
yeah do I have it right you were sitting
and strumming the guitar that was tough
I had a feeling you could hear me
because he could squeeze your hand so I
just played the song
[Music]
[Music]
it's a song it's it yeah it's it's a
hymn you have any tricks in songwriting
first thing you want is a good metaphor
I'm playing and I'm singing but I'm
listening too
if I'm creating that sensation for me I
know I'm creating it for you
[Music]
finally got me to cry on the air it's
the first time ever wow
[Music]